There is a second huge story from the leaked
audio recording of this dinner that Donald
Trump had with Lev Parness, who he claims
not to know as well as Igor Fruman, both Rudy
Giuliani henchmen, who have since been indicted.
Uh, Donald Trump's comments in the recording
confirm that Donald Trump is scared of Bernie
Sanders.
Now, this is very interesting because a couple
of weeks ago I got a live call during, during
our audience call segment from a viewer who
said, Hey David, have you noticed that Trump
doesn't really criticize Bernie much?
He goes after Biden.
He goes after Warren, but he doesn't.
He went after Hillary and still goes after
Hillary, but he doesn't really go after Bernie
Sanders very much and it's basically true.
Trump calls him crazy Bernie.
He's nicknamed him, but he doesn't really
go hard against Bernie and we suspected it
could be that Donald Trump actually is sort
of scared of Bernie.
He thinks Bernie could actually do well against
him in the recording.
Donald Trump actually admits this in the audio
I'm about to play for you.
Donald Trump admits that if Hillary had chosen
Bernie as her running mate in 2016 instead
of milk toast, Tim Kaine, that it would've
been tougher for Trump, that Bernie, as Trump
sees it, Bernie is similar on trade.
He has a similar message.
People are getting screwed on trade.
That Bernie would've been a tougher opponent
and this is part of a long recording that
was leaked.
This part hasn't been getting as much attention.
It really should.
Let's take a listen to it
because he was half my motivation and more
games was let her dog 100% [inaudible] vice
president.
It would've been tougher.
Kane was on the, I couldn't because all those
people then ended her so much.
Who wrote for me?
You know I got 20% of Bernie loved people
and all that stuff because the trade, cause
he's a big trick, you know, he's basically
says we're getting screwed up and he's right.
I'm worse than he is and we can do something
about it.
I don't know if he could've had she think
Bernie Sanders would have been tougher cause
you only want, I didn't want her to think.
Now
it's right there.
We've suspected this for a long time and there
is Donald from saying it now.
Trump is wrong on on facts all the time.
Trump may have been scared of Bernie for no
reason.
Like what I mean is just because Trump believes
Bernie would've been the toughest to run against
this VP.
Doesn't mean Bernie would have been the toughest
to run against this VP.
Maybe he would.
Maybe he wouldn't.
That's not actually what we're debating here.
But this is terrific fodder for Bernie Sanders
to now run on and even include in ads.
Trump said he's afraid of Bernie Sanders.
And case in point as an example of just because
Trump thinks something doesn't mean it's true.
In that audio I played for you.
Trump says, I got 20% of Bernie voters.
That's not true.
It was half that Trump was off by, uh, by
half.
One out of 10, Bernie supporters ultimately
voted for Trump, not two out of 10.
And that's roughly in line with the percentage
of, uh, of other party switches in the past.
Uh, Hillary supporters in 2008 that ultimately
voted for John McCain, for example, instead
of Barack Obama.
Still shocking to me.
I don't agree with it.
And Trump doesn't even remotely seem like
a reasonable substitute to Bernie unless you're
trying to burn it all down because your candidate
lost.
But one out of 10 Bernie supporters did ultimately
vote for Trump in 2016.
Regardless, this is a gift if you are Bernie
Sanders.
This is something that should be repeated
by campaign surrogates used in campaign ads
and made a huge deal of by Bernie Sanders.
Any reasonable person would also say, well,
Trump also seems to be afraid of Biden.
He extorted Ukraine to smear Biden and he
didn't do that for other possible opponents.
That's certainly true, but this helps Bernie's
image significantly, so let's now give it
a few days.
We'll see if this is used by the Sanders campaign,
whether it moves the needle in any way.
I actually don't know how many people are
following the entire leaked audio story.
There was surprisingly less coverage of it
than I imagined there would be.
There was other news over the weekend, including
the tragic death of of Kobe Bryant with wood
without passing, without passing any value
judgments.
It took a lot of media coverage hours and
this leaked audio thing, particularly the
Bernie Trump part did not get a lot of attention.
But this tape, as I said earlier, must be
made part of the impeachment trial evidence.
It will put it in front of more people and
Bernie Sanders should also be using this to
bolster his own campaign.
Can you covering this on Instagram?
Make sure you are following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
While you're there.
Follow me on instagram@daviddotpacmanaswellthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com